thousands of unemployment claimants
paying close attention to the stimulus
bill currently on the table
congress is expected to pass that bill
tonight it would include
six hundred dollars checks to americans
who make less than seventy five thousand
dollars a year
joe moeller is live with more details
joe
yeah we've been getting questions about
this for weeks now now this new bill
that's on the table what extent benefits
for thousands of people including gig
workers which
a lot of them have been wondering
because that is set to expire this week
while a lot of people are happy about
the news of this but some still have
concerns here in nevada
it's going to help out that about equals
what my paycheck was before
nobody is likely as anxious to hear
about the stimulus build and
unemployment claimants in nevada
six hundred dollars does not sound like
a lot it's
half of the other stimulus bill but it's
a help not only does it include a six
hundred dollar stimulus check to most
americans but it will also extend
benefits for unemployment
claimants that includes pua the program
in place for gig workers and independent
contractors
pua was set to expire this month melissa
schilling says her daughter is still
waiting for her claim to be processed
and she is helping it'll help like i
said pay bills
it'll help buy food
you know it'll just catch things up a
little in the summer the karazak extra
weekly payments of six hundred dollars
ended for claimants this new bill brings
that bonus back
but it lowers it to three hundred
dollars a week that'll at least help
cover all the bills i know everything
will be able to take care of rent
um electricity no gas the concern for
many moving forward
is if dieter can disperse this money
timely claimants have contacted 8 news
now about missing lost wages benefits
dated from september
elijah had several payments delayed you
look at
just the number of issues that has
happened anytime they try to do anything
absolutely there's a major cause for
concern that you know after next week i
might be sitting here for a couple of
weeks with no pay
and this evening we actually do have an
update regarding lost wages assistance
been getting a lot of questions a lot of
people wondering where is week five a
lot of regular ui claimants well that's
still being paid out uh dieter a short
time ago did give me an update they say
due to i.t limitations
it has been going slower but it is still
going out they expect it to take at
least
another week so week five still going
out there i know a lot of people have
been having questions about week four as
well we're still trying to get that
but as far as the next payment some are
expecting week six there's no word on if
that is happening dieter
is still waiting on an update from fema
reporting live joe mohler eight news now